St perius is gaza's oldest active Church
it is also one of the oldest in the
world and the only Greek Orthodox Church
in Gaza now parts of it are
rubble and some fear Israel's war on
Gaza may also signal the start of its
end as a Christian place of worship and
Sanctuary for others remember this is
one of the oldest uh Christian
communities in the whole world um we
have only one ,000 Christians less than
1,000 Christians left in Gaza and now we
fear this will be the last generation
the last age for this church and this is
very very sad the church is named after
St pierus a Christian Bishop who came to
Gaza to fight paganism and Shepherd
Christians 1600 years ago the first
church was built on this site where he
is believed to be buried around 425 ad
in the 12th century Crusaders built a
larger church here and named it after
the saint it was renovated in the middle
of the 19th century adding most elements
that were visible before Thursday's
attack it's one Landmark uh of of the
Christian history it's very known to be
to be a place where people worship uh
and go even for tourism to to see it to
watch it is architecture and its
composition the church has opened it
doors to refugees from Gaza V in 2014
around 2,000 sheltered there for days to
escape Israeli
bombardment and like then today the
church is promising to keep its doors
open to anyone in need by blessing of
God we have to continue our life in Gaza
as a Christian Community Demitri madeno
Al jazer